we are closing out mental health
awareness month with a story of strength
and resilience from a member of our very
own CBS News family producer Adam
zielins has worked at CBS morning since
2015 and is a major part of our team our
staff here and two years ago he survived
a violent assault on a New York City
sidewalk for the first time Adam is
publicly sharing his story about exactly
what happened that day and in an essay
he wrote for us he details his mental
and physical recovery
okay
for nearly two years I was lost
I felt attached from my identity and
detached from reality
28 with 24 stitches along my jawline I
was stitched to my trauma
on May 30th 2021 I was assaulted
I was attacked on Fifth Avenue it was
drizzly gray and quiet
to assailants surrounded me I cried for
help my voice carried away with the wind
I was left silenced
I fell to the ground skin hitting hard
Stone my personhood crushed by the
assault
I summoned the strength to lift myself
off the ground a decision fight or
flight
Iran the assailants fled
in that moment the rain washing off my
skin and body
I looked down to see the sidewalk water
colored and red dye
I got myself to an emergency room nurses
wrapped me in towels it was then that I
learned my face was slashed
the human mind is a fragile thing fickle
but also protective
I have no memory of the slash to my face
I was diagnosed with PTSD working with a
psychiatrist a therapist and even a
plastic surgeon
I was terrified and easily triggered by
cars honking by an approaching Subway by
the cacophony of City Construction
I retreated from reality from family
from friends from work
I began to live in an isolation I
created and felt myself descending into
it
I had to remind myself
you are brave you were courageous you
were filled with pride
I felt strangers eyes trailing along my
jawline hearing into my most traumatic
moment I sought to memorialize My New
Self
I found a photographer for a portrait
session
I needed to reintroduce myself to the
world
I needed to reintroduce myself to me
but despite this I was resentful jealous
of the normalcy around me
I sought release
I sought relief I sought Joy
I read and read and read Didion Capote
Ephron
200 books in 2021
185 in 2022
amidst searching bookshelves I was
really seeking a distraction
searching for a story that wasn't my own
foreign
walking across Manhattan
10 miles became 12 miles became 19 miles
I witnessed daily changes to the city
around me hoping I too could create my
own change
every step was healing every day was a
step toward progress
the assailants
I worked to remove them from my daily
battles I testified twice before grand
jury crying through my story
I looked out before me the jury crying
too
[Music]
even as I'm here now
I feel the stress and anxiety and heart
palpitations
that I felt two years ago
and I'm reminded that the Sacred Space
is now a part of me and who I am today
long ago the blood washed away
Fifth Avenue is no longer haunting each
year I find beauty in myself I find
beauty in my strength
[Applause]
I remind myself progress isn't always
linear
I am the architect of my own healing
rebuilding myself
returning to work
traveling with family
morning runs through Central Park
and yes I continue to read even more
books
I found myself
and you know what I really like who I
see in the mirror
and resilience
resilience
a word initially a stranger to my lips
me
resilient
I'm resilient once I was knocked down
but today I stand tall
[Music]
[Applause]
Stand Tall Adam yeah and tall I mean we
knew he was a talented producer I didn't
know quite such a beautiful writer as
well uh before we get into more reaction
we should say that if you or someone you
know is seeking Mental Health Resources
you can call the National Alliance on
Mental Health helpline
1-800-950-6264 or in a crisis text
helpline to 62640 but let's talk Adam
zeelands because that is a beautiful
piece of writing he just put together
there and it was so brave of him to also
share his story I mean you think about
how one moment of being in the wrong
place at the wrong time can shape so
many things in his life but I love that
he said he is the architect of my own
healing and the picture and epitome of
resilience and how he has continued and
in reading so many stories to be able to
Define his own too I think we can all
take something from that he said I found
beauty in myself beauty and my strength
and I took away that he also found
beauty in that scar yes and we all can
do that yes we all can find beauty in
our scars whether the scars that people
see or the ones that we hide that's well
said it's a beautiful thing
well done